hey welcome to the monitor
we're back as always i'm peter rubin
senior editor at
wired and you know what's nice about
this week specifically what is nice
about today
archer starts tonight which means we are
going back to the danger zone
call kenny loggins on fx thursday nights
created by adam reed who you may also
know as the co-creator of sealab
2021 holy crap
what have you done and that same
demented humor has winded its way
through his career
making a way a way stop for frisky dingo
and on to archer which begins its fourth
season tonight
now what's so wonderful about this not
only does it have that great bold line
contoured uh animation that that is so
kind of recognizable and enjoyable
but the voice work is impeccable
thoughts
yeah shut up shut up oh shut up shut up
no running shut up imagine shutting up
john benjamin who plays the titular
character
friend of wired aisha tyler who plays
lana kane she's also got an essay in the
current issue of wired on stands now so
read that it is about her
you'll enjoy it uh and a bunch of other
great uh work chris parnell judy greer a
lot of comedy all-stars in there
fantastic writing really twisted so many
kind of throwaway easter eggy jokes
it's not necessarily the kind of show
you can jump right into but i imagine
that if you watch this show
you've heard of this this show being the
monitor and you've heard of archer so
you probably know exactly what i'm
talking about but in case you didn't
know
four season starts tonight and let's
talk about comics
well i get to learn karate karate the
dane cook of martial arts
no now i talk a lot about image comics
in here and i've talked a lot about
marvel comics in here i haven't talked a
ton
about dc i you know batman certainly
and when dial age for hero started i
talked about that but it's been a while
since i talked about a new dc title
but starting up this week is well a
couple new books but the one i want to
talk about
is called threshold now
you know the background is this kind of
stems from
you're going to hate me for saying this
green lantern the new guardian's annual
there's no reason that you need to read
this to get the background it's not a
very good issue it's a little confusing
and too many characters get thrown in
the wall
but what comes out of that is there is a
kind of different
uh disgraced green lantern character and
there's also
this game show called hunted basically
you are conscripted into this not that
unlike the hunger games and you are on
the run and basically
everyone in the tenebrian dominion gets
to hunt you chase you down for untold
riches
and that's what happens in threshold
number one with this poor disgraced
green lantern
so he's in civilian clothes he's on the
run there's also kind of a secondary
featured storyline in the back of the
issue that'll be going through the next
few issues
but it is written by keith giffin art by
tom rainey i kind of enjoy the art
i'm not that familiar with tom rainey's
stuff keith gibbon wasn't involved with
green lantern new guardians
but he is making his mark on threshold
it it's i'm not that
into space superhero stuff
if if that's a kind of strange
qualification to make but i enjoyed this
uh it and it puts a lot of people in
mind of marvel's guardians of the galaxy
which of course will be coming to big
screens in a couple of years
and there's a lot on tap it seems for
threshold
and i'm going to check it out for a few
months see what it amounts to but in the
meantime that is out this week and you
can pick that up
so that's comics and let's talk about
music posited
you know that rap has been around for a
very long time
when the album i want to talk about this
week is by a kid whose actual birth name
is rakim
which means that he was born when rakim
was doing
his thing in the late eighties long live
asap is out this week
asap rocky is out of harlem along with
the rest of his asap crew
and and he came to prominence with a
song called peso which was this really
slow almost kind of chop and screw
houstony feeling
song didn't sound a lot like a new york
rapper as he's gotten kind of more
confident
and uh more high profile he's kind of
grown into where he's from not that you
should need to sound like where you're
from but
asap rocky is you know i was actually
pleasantly surprised by how accomplished
this album is for his first kind of
official major label album
specifically there is a song on here
it's called one train
and it is it is
it is among the best posse cuts that
that have ever been committed to tape
i'm just gonna say it i mean you've got
scenario
you've got banned from tv you've got so
many great
posse cuts but think about this lineup
asap rocky kendrick lamar joey badass
action bronson
yellow wolf uh big crit and i might be
missing one
but that's that is ridiculous and they
they all do their thing it is an
astonishing song it's a really good
album it is out this week and that is
long live asap long live asap however
you want to pronounce if that's on you
i'm not going to tell rock him or rocky
and neither should you but that's it for
the monitor this week we will be back
next week with more pop culture but
until then
inspirational catchphrase here